I spent you know I I'm terrible at all
but 18 holes with the captain of the
team I'll say yes every time a girl
recognized him she ran over for a selfie
and an autograph she's like oh you can
save my Instagram you know like women at
that level when they see a guy like that
it was crazy for me because I've never
been treated by women like that just
just transparently I didn't know that
was a thing right the way that women
treat those guys like it's like the way
that guys treat the most beautiful woman
they ever see like they're getting DMS
these guys they're getting approached on
the street like it's just crazy well I
think that's where like a lot of times
the red pill and like the Chad cons kind
of get into arguments because it's like
the red the tradcon guys will be like
well you should never cheat on your wife
and it's like some of the red pill guys
are like well you've never been in that
position you know and so it's like
they'll be like shaming the the guys
that cheat for like being in a position
they've never been in I've talked